Vừa tới sinh bay ca zan, tu tưởng leming hơn đã được đòn tiếp bằng nhi thức trên thống bánh mi và mối,
cùng món chắc chắc đặc trưng của người ta ta.
Tu tưởng leming hơn và đòn đại biểu cấp cao Việt Nam hạ cánh xuống sinh bay ca zan
thuộc vụ cộng hoa ta ta stan thuộc ngà vào chiều mùi sảo thằng sau.
Đón tu tưởng tại sinh bay là ông Rústang Minh di khán lof người đứng đầu cộng hoa ta ta stan.
Lãnh đạo Việt Nam được tiếp đón bằng nhi thức trên thống bánh mi và mối, thế hiện sự hiểu khác.
Thủ tưởng cũng được mời thường thức món chắc chắc là bánh trưng thống của người ta ta làm thứ bột chiên đường và mặt ông.
Đây là chuyến công tác đầu tiên của thủ tưởng leming hơn trên cân vị mới tới ngà,
giữa hội nghi cấp cao ki những 3-6 quán hệ a xe ăn ngà từ mấy bẩy đến mở chiến thằng sau,
theo lấy mời của tổng thống Vladimir Putin.
Chong khuôn khổ chuyến công tác, thủ tưởng cũng giữ kiến hội kiến tổng thống ngà Vladimir Putin
và làm việc với người đứng đầu cộng hoa ta ta stan.